[Musique]
m
ce terrain là
mieux
non
[Musique]
là
c'est
[Musique]
hamada manoir
là
[Musique]
m
non
[Musique]
l'adolescence c'est le moment où on
commence à découvrir vraiment la vie que
nos parents ont prévu pour nous imaginez
qu'on force un adulte à monter dans une
voiture qu'on l'éloignent de chez lui et
de ses copains sans lui demander son
avis moi j'appelle ça un rapt eu un
déménagement
les parents nous apprennent que les
promesses c'est sacré que la famille ce
qui est plus important est que l'amour
c'est pour toute la vie puis après ils
oublient tous à leur plus grand mensonge
c'est sur l'adolescence il te retire
tous les avantages de l'enfance mais il
t'en donne aucun des adultes
bon bah on est arrivé
bienvenue dans notre nouvelle vie dis
moi que c'est pas ici
dis moi s'il te plaît tu tapes acheter
ça il faudra faire quelques petits
travaux mais il est travaux d'une boule
de démolition arrête n'exagère pas le
bar a beaucoup de possibilités dans un
quartier vraiment bien c'est ici et
l'appartement est énorme
berthet oui oui c'est moi excusez moi je
vais vous apporter
oui merci et il ya une livraison qui est
arrivé ce matin un cadeau d'un certain
emilio molina tata
[Musique]
sur deux roues la vie est plus joli à
très bientôt
une fois de plus je vais être méchant du
film balle mal vu de ce n'est pas un
village conduire ici c'est la folie tu
ne peux pas non plus de me priver de
samara commence à amara moi je veux des
privés de rien de rien tu m'a éloigné de
la maison de papa et on veut tous gagner
tout seul
bon parlons tous aller mes copains quoi
tu m'as sortie du bail au milieu d'année
tu me traîne jusqu'à madrid mais il dit
tiens si jamais je te vois sans casque
ya plus coûteux
[Musique]
un gars
ap
[Musique]
tu
je ne sais pas
causeway
[Musique]
ouais allait bien ah merde j'ai rien
fait j'ai une cassée ce serait dommage
d'être cassé quelque chose de premier
jour non
ok merci pour l'accueil est ce que tu as
besoin d aide
non merci attend une seconde la salle 4
lé haut à droite
je
bonjour tout le monde
si seulement je pouvais dire en personne
ce que j'écris sur ce blogue
puisque de cette manière mon secret n'en
serait plus un je t'aime coeur car là
est bon on va bien se marrer quand on
sera que c'est un mec d'ici qui écrit ce
blog
excuse moi un mec c'est trop mignon
excusez moi une fille quoi qui est assis
sur mon scooter
ouais mais ici c'est ma place de parking
j'avais pas que les passes étaient
attribués pas de souci c'est moi qui ai
pas beaucoup de choses que tu sais pas
entre autres que les salopettes c'est
démodé
tiens moi ça et cette chemise à carreaux
alors on a l'air tout faire mieux je
sais pas en tout cas tu as l'air d'une
vache quoi répète un peu pour voir allez
vas-y répète là je suis dans mon bureau
vous deux ils vont dire et j'ai promis
aux proviseurs que ça n'arrivera plus
mais étaient bonnes pour l'éducateur
ckoi l'éducateur écoute tu donnes finale
et confettis le divorce le déménagement
le changement de lycée en pleine année
scolaire
ça fera du bien d'en parler à quelqu'un
c'est comme un psychologue mais nous
voyons ce n'est pas un psychologue mais
après les cours il ya un groupe de
soutien avec des ados de ton âge ça
fonctionne très bien
pas question bien concret mais truc
perso adversaire tu peux te faire des
copains louis des copains contestataires
qui se bat avec les jeux ne seront pas
contestataires il ya tout là ça me
rassure c'est ce que tu veux et toi tu
veux scooter c'est un cadeau de papa tu
le vois paris sitôt papa
valeria c'est ça oui mais c'est que
vient m'assieds toi il s'agit d'une
erreur je devrais pas être ici web mail
et les pieds dit martin tu es vraiment
mignon aujourd'hui tu t'appelles
valérien molina c'est ça oui mais
j'imagine que vous avez vos problèmes et
vos histoires et ça n'a aucun sens que
je reste ici sans parler de recruter
battu avec le camarade je me suis pas
battue c'était pas une camarade et j'ai
rien n'arrête atteint 10 mois valeria
était une fausse blonde ou une vraie
brune bonjour bonsoir
bon on va faire un jeu valeria tu
commences choisi un camarade lens lui la
balle et définit le avec un adjectif
mais j'en connais pas encore mieux on va
parler aujourd'hui des préjugés
ensuite cette personne dira quelque
chose de toi quand tu voudras
aimable pour mes allées raul c'est à toi
choisi un camarade mauviette glandeurs
silencieuse non non non non non d'abord
tu dois dire quelque chose de lui
victime ben je sais pas pourquoi vous
pensez que je suis une victime parce que
moi je crois pas première de la classe
inconnu je voudrais pas l'offensé au
qu'est-ce que tu es mignonne mais
n'inquiète pas payer forte non plus les
préjugés ne sont pas toujours très c'est
vrai vas-y petit gars frigide pour qui
tu te prends les filles ça suffit il
habite maintenant essayer de dire
quelque chose de positif d'un camarade
si c'est possible
d'accord les courageuses il était temps
que quelqu'un ose affronter cette débile
de béatrice attend pardon c'est toi qui
a frappé ma copine ta copine écoute j'ai
traduit d'accord je change promis par
agressif qu'est ce que t'en penses quoi
j'ai progressive ta copine est rendu là
tu faire bâle a raison cette nana n'est
rien d'autre qu'une bouffonne qui sature
ouais t'as un problème moi je suis pas
venu ici pour qu'on m'insulte bon je
pense qu'il a lancé aujourd'hui à les
vétérans de chez le coiffeur et pas
diplomatique
[Musique]
on
je t'explique sait pas toujours comme ça
il ya des fois personnes crient ce qui
arrive quand on s'enfermait avec cette
bande mais toi en direct et des films
foute la paix tu vois se laisser diviser
il ya la bande est super chiant il ya
les gens spéciaux j'ai un don pour voir
ces choses là
et toi tu spécial chéri et comment on
fait pour les différencier
trop facile moi j'ai spéciale très
spécial pas les autres
tu recommences il ya des choses que les
gens doivent savoir
je suis d'accord bah quand tu auras fini
tu ne passeras le spray j'ai des choses
à dire sur ton micro pénis tire toi ton
ex
moi j'ai pas de mec quand je me fais que
j'ai largué je passe au suivant
certains entraînements galerie qu'est ce
que tu fais à épouvanter les prétendants
à demain
[Musique]
bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est beau il va également voir
l'éducateur amant et la réunion la
réunion vraiment normal bonne ambiance à
vrai dire tout et sérieuse s'il y en a
d'autres comme lui je suis partante ne
déconne pas qu'est ce que tu n'es pas la
salle qui doit refaire sa vie
tu pourrais de sa grand mère
au contraire je te promets tu vas voir
[Rires]
avec sa constance à part constanza le
nom d'un bar est vraiment important j'ai
besoin que tu me dises que tu aimes non
non non coutu même nom que tu kiffes
grave
ce qui est grave et que tout ira bien
ce tir a bien et qu'on a bien fait de
changer de maison
maman s'il te plait je sais ce que tu en
penses même en moi il faut que je
l'entende tautira super bien au moins
pour toi
bon je lui donne cinq minutes de plus un
s'il n'arrive pas je me barre parce que
j'ai un plein et quand je dis un blanc
se veut d'ailleurs on a très bien
compris merci
pas de quoi et toi tu joues toi pauvre
petit tu joues mois alors voyons je suis
peut-être un glandeur mais je suis pas
comme break it charia fond bon en fait
c'est pas de ce foot jamais de lui il le
fera pas vrai ben non feutre il me fera
pas ouais tu peux te mentir à toi-même
oui mais à nous tous les gens du lycée
savent bien la façon dont ces connards
te traite
ben c'est ma bande de potes j'étais
bonne vieille bonne blague est là
pourquoi est ce que tu es ici
bonjour pourquoi tu es là
ben parce que mes parents exagère
toujours un peu et meiwey et toi
pourquoi est ici et bien parce que mes
parents n'exagère pas toujours bon alors
aux garçons contre filles ça vous va bon
d'accord il ya un nouveau poste de j'ai
un secret j'ai un secret encore un oui
c'est un blog anonyme écrit par
quelqu'un dubaï ou un truc d'une
ringardise qui arrange tout le monde
bah moi je meurs d'envié de savoir qui c
est qui et ce quart et carla dont il est
amoureux tu joues j'aimerais bien mais
comme il n'arrive pas je refermais de
voir bon tu peux faire tes devoirs après
j'ai joué avec nous maintenant
non j'ai entraînement de volée et après
je vais à devenir si j'avais autant
d'activités mes parents serai vraiment
heureux tu vois pour les miens course
assez peu de choses aller et toi tu
viens tu viens pas aller
[Musique]
car
non
ouais très bien leicester c'est très
bien
salut
merci bien
[Rires]
vous êtes des tricheurs qui nous oui
c'est des mecs ils ont ça dans le sang
d'abord il bat pour qu'on joue avec eux
et puis quoi encore c'est fou quand vous
attaquez vous faites toujours plus de
pâques il faudrait [ __ ] quel culot pas
vrai es tu toi je sais pas j'ai jamais
joué avec des filles j'espèrais
réveille-toi abruti on est en train de
parler d'autre chose là d'accord ah ah
c'est pas comme je suis pour mais c'est
exactement pour ça que je veux pas avoir
de make way parce que tu joues avec des
petites équipes
comment bah si tu joue en régionale
personne ne traite pas comme tu le
mérites
qu'est ce t'en penses à l'arrière ouais
toi vu que tu es de la ligue antilles
mais qu on parle bien ça non meiway
[ __ ] c'est pas pour l'instant je suis
plutôt sur la touche regard d'amour
depuis le banc des remplaçants alors
qu'est ce que tu attends ben j'attends
qu'apparaissent la personne parfaite
celle qui quand je serai à ses côtés me
donnera envie tout et le reste de ma vie
et sinon on bat kim incitera à
m'entraîner pour la revoir
elle croit sérieuse là allez on se tient
bon si je le trouve je t'appelle
d'accord allez et toi c'est le sac à
main de marque voir dans le métro c'est
sûr ça se remarque
est ce que tu es au chômage j'en fait
pas un fromage
gachnang faire
mon frère au fil de fer tu m'écoutes un
frangin ne lui lâche ma main surtout pas
avant demain
l'amour c'est pas humain là j'ai dit
humain
et tu me prêtes temps sur une seconde je
l'offre à sa super copine et jonah
dévergonde mais pardon je vous laisse le
rap est toujours en liesse salut
[Musique]
tu t'en vas
ça marche pas on dirait un petit coup de
main non alors une pièce pour la musique
ou désolé je vais devoir acheter un
billet j'ai pas d'argent
laisse moi faire qu'est ce que tu fais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu es arrivé je suis même pas si c'est
ma ligne
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment belle
après des mois
aujourd'hui on va parler des choses dont
on a peur ça vous va
et ne me dites pas les araignées je vous
connais tu espères les araignées bon
allez c est recalé grossir perdreaux
need for speed rail veulent se perdre au
call of duty 11h public quoi je suis
maladroite et bien moi j'ai peur de rien
ouais c'est ça ça c'est impossible
moi j'ai peur d'avoir un zéro décevoir
mes parents c'est assez courant
moi aussi ça m'arrive il te met beaucoup
de pression suffisamment pour avoir des
crises d angoisse c'est pour ça que fils
ben moi j'ai peur de vouloir un petit
ami dans quelques années et que ça
marche pas tu as peur de de ne pas
rencontrer le garçon parfait
j'ai peur de ne pas être aimée
abl
ben moi ma plus grande peur c'est que le
lycée ne finissent jamais
que quelqu'un me connaissent vraiment
parce que peut-être que je pleurais pas
je préférais bizarre plutôt que
monstrueuse j'avais peur que madrid me
plaisent et ça commence à me plaire
vachement mais surtout j'avais peur de
pas avoir de nouveaux copains mais je
crois que ça va pas être un problème
tu y as pensé oui les araignées
non qu'est ce que tu as et tu veux plus
te mau motu qua non c'est que je lâche à
papa ah non mais qu'est ce qu'ils valent
j'ai rendez vous chez celle endocrines
et ça c'est quoi la pire excuses du
monde pour qu'on fait pas la gueule
rester un peu et ce petit sac à dos
c'est mignon ça longtemps que j'allais
qu est ce que t as bouffon 1 comment tu
te sens gens qui racontent qu est-ce que
ta maman a préparé la jambon fromage
sandwich jambon sur wii garde un peu
taper un peu ton t-shirt mais qu à les
localiser tous les témoins je n'en sais
rien du tout valérien ctd bon pote c3 et
ses lacets qui 7,1 me comment ça va tu
veux jouer avec nous touchons à cheveux
et tu verras imbéciles qu'est ce que tu
dis la puce
gfr et quoi exactement
wei laisse tomber raoult est épinglé de
défense et de la ferme là et raul tu me
parle pas comme ça je suis ta copine non
c'est fini
quoi battus les plus j'en ai marre ça
lui est question mon gars vas-y
écoute-moi la casse toi on te retrouver
seul bah non il est pas seul
si tu veux les cogner tu devrais me
casser la gueule d'abord est la mienne
est la mienne aussi
ouais
allez tous les enfants avaient comparé
toi même
m
[Musique]
[Rires]
ouais mais vous avez vu la tronche de
régler trouver
merci beaucoup vont avoir encore plus
envie de cogner et toi ça va c'était pas
des ta copine maintenant j'ai de
nouveaux copains un peu zarbi mais bon
non pas harbi on est des a compris on
sera le club des incompris la junte des
à-coups prix c'est nous
[Rires]
je pense qu'on devrait fêter ça ma mère
inaugure son bar si vous voulez il nous
est invité mine de rien je crois que ça
va être le plus beau jour de ma vie j'ai
tu peux compter sur moi à galeria
moi aussi je peux on se voit au lycée
d'accord non non non non attends mairie
on est un club
ben c'est que j'aime pas trop les fêtes
à lundi d'accords mairie je m'en occupe
il est où ton bar tout près d'ici à
vingt minutes à peu près mais elle était
là et voir à temps at war on voit pas le
temps souriait bon j'arrive entre elle
et bien ouais super maman le bar marché
rien ma fille qui serait inquiété mais
blake sa mère parce que je vois les
réunions avec l'éducateur marche bien
aussi
d'accord je reconnais peut-être que
madrid c'est pas si mal et donc madrid
c'est pas si mal
tu veux que je t'aide va y aller
je finirai par détester ce bar à cause
de lui ce qu'est la ne durera pas pour
toujours
ah oui oui fallait rien m'a beaucoup
parlé de toi et plus beau en personne tu
veux que je te montre un truc sympa bien
sûr
quand les beaux jours arriveront ma mère
veut ouvrir une terrasse
regarde le ciel
à quoi tu penses quand j'étais petit mon
père m'emmenait à la pêche et à la
tombée de la nuit
il me racontait des histoires sur les
constellations toutes les étoiles ont
des souvenirs et l'une d'entre elles te
rappelle béatrice non mais a été une
étoile filante
et le nantes c'est étoile qui brille
tant la gueule
celle là
celle là c'est pas une étoile
c'est jupiter
salut on a apporté à boire voirie sa
décision d'avoir ma maison ah ouais oui
c'est pour toi c'est génial et valent
bien par ici
[Musique]
attends attends
il
samedi 22h place sainte-anne à bon
compte et pas sûr - mary ainsi toi faut
qu'on dirait que je déteste les fêtes je
déteste les étudiants et les cartes
d'identité faudra bien là en tout ces
fringues et derrière ses lunettes
chaussures qui ne fait pas non mais
voilà avec tout ça ce sera top et lit
écoute chez pas comme m à madrid tout le
monde s'habille très chouette et moins
ringard ouais vous apporter ça on va
voir si vous aimez valeria tout ce que
tu veux tu me le demande merci beaucoup
merci maman 1
d'accord cette robe mauve à part messi a
une aura mais si je te dis je
[Applaudissements]
je ne plante pas bonne presse
nissan patrol poèmes
au non respect
ciao
chicago
allez
tu sais dépêchons-nous être en retard
mais non faut se faire désirer
t'inquiète pas mon décolleté il est
comment on remarque que rien t'es
sérieux pour s'afficher sur quelqu'un
c'est pour ça qu'on va cette fête les
plus âgés que nous non il à notre âge et
oui va aller à la paix les du lycée je
connais les surtout le connais tu t'es
vraiment pas rendu compte mais c'est
raul
tu crois pas que ce serait le meilleur
petit copain du monde tu es gala pour
avec lui à partir de demain je serai une
autre et lis bien plus sérieuse plus
formel plus stable bref j'aurais un mec
[Rires]
mais t'es super mignonne télé
tu vas te cacher c'est à moi
regardez
[Musique]
le corps ne l'est pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça charmant
rich hanley
[Applaudissements]
m
alors mon père répond ben je m'en vais à
barcelone elle ma mère lui réponds bah
vas-y et mon père lui répond je pas
vraiment un et ma mère les réponses tire
toi alors et c'est ça tous les jours
une ambiance pourrie en fait les
relations c'est la merde
[Applaudissements]
quoi j'en fais pas trop non je voudrais
pas l'effrayer ça va elie je dois dire
quelque chose
ok bah tu me diras après tu pourrais pas
rejoindre les autres nous apporter un
verre un jeune serveuse
ouais je sais mais tu es ma copine et
j'aimerais bien que tu me laisses seul
avec qui un instant d'accord
autant
gemma
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais la fille du métro la fille du métro
mais alors tu arrêtes pas de fuir
qu'est ce qui était arrivé là bas j'ai
pas l'habitude de raconter ma vie à des
mecs qui s'incruste dans les faits main
que c'est dans ces fêtes de bush se dit
nora je fais pas ça c'est pas mon truc
qui a rien à [ __ ] là bas on m'a
surpris en train de trafiquer super tu
t'améliores non non non non non pas de
drogue des fausses cartes d'identité de
qualité toute façon tu es bien encore de
tous âges effet la tienne laura je
m'appelle pas l'aura bien sur la photo
tu avais la tête d'une laura si tu ris
encore je ferai de cette soirée la
meilleure soirée de ta vie qu'est ce que
t'en dis je m'appelle césar et j'ai
l'intention jamais de décevoir
la fille du métro ont chanté tu t'es
déjà complet avec un truc de science je
veux dire non non alors viens viens
salut ça c'est mes potes c'est parti
13 heures
sebha
[Applaudissements]
césar
ça
m
voilà
[Musique]
tiens moi
je me suis super bien les musées ce soir
mais il est temps que j'entre chez moi
mais non mais non il nous reste encore
toute la nuit
tu surveilles qu'est ce que tu fais on y
va j'ai pas l'intention d'entrer
qu'est-ce qu'il ya la hourre un césar tu
m'écoutes je vois que tu aimes bien
attirer des ennuis mais moi non je me
tire et toi tu vas nulle part qui se
fout lâche moi je te dis je te connais
pas du tout tu vas tu y seras tu verras
le choix c'est ça ou enfin lâche moi
césar c'est vraiment pas drôle a on va
tomber tu te croit malin mais c'est ce
que
c'est pas mal hein
c'est super beau ouais je vais
t'embrasser quoi je vais t'en brasser et
ben c'est pas mal pour ton premier
baiser un essai cet abruti bon allez
sous quel nom je garde la fille du métro
aucun en eau est les mauvaises tu vas
pas me le dire
non tu es sûr je suis sûr et bien c'est
ce qu'on va voir comment mais pour qui
tu te prends césar lâchement
comment tu t'appelles je te dirai pas ah
non regarde en bas regarde en bas
ça fout la trouille 1
comment tu t'appelles
bah comment
j'ai pas entendu valeria j'ai pas
entendu
[Rires]
raul qu'est ce que tu fais ici je
voulais te parler c'est pas la peine que
tu me racontes quoi que ce soit
félicitations et ailier bon sens pas
ensemble ni maintenant ni jamais j'ai
pas largué pea pour sortir avec une nana
comédie tu as tort elle est parfaite non
toi qui est parfaite
j'adore être avec toi
parler avec toi et même si tu penses que
c'est con j'adore le parfum des cheveux
et de façon de rire
tu te rends pas compte
que je veux pas être avec élie
que je veux être avec toi
désolé
[Musique]
ce
elle se tait
raul
tu as passé toute la nuit si on a
quelque chose à régler non t'es cinglé
tas dé gêner ma mère a ouvert le bar je
t'invite non
on prend ton scoot et c'est moi qui
habite
joyeuse saint valentin
qu'est ce que tu es mais quand à vue
pour qu'ils laissent entrer les bas
parce que j'ai pas toujours été un as
compris
j'ai même des amis au pôle sud de veigné
[Rires]
[Musique]
j'arrive pas à croire que tu as préparé
tout ça
et moi que tu ne me répond pas qu'est ce
que tu veux que je te dise ça a été la
nuit la plus longue de ma vie est la
mienne et a réfléchi j'ai pas à
réfléchir
raul les choses sont claires pour moi je
t'ai envoyé un pas de signaux mais quels
signaux je suis un mec
les mecs ne comprennent pas les signaux
ouais je vois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
joyeuse saint valentin
j'aurais jamais pensé que tu dirais ça
et je le dirai jamais enfin sérieusement
ouais t'as fait tomber quelque chose
vient pas
regarde un anonyme
quelqu'un de la classe il dit qu'il est
amoureux de moi mais qu'il n'ose pas me
le dire
et alors et il a écrit une liste de tous
les mecs de la classe il veut que je
mette qui me plaît et que je laisse la
carte sous l'arbre de la cour en fin de
journée si mon nom n'est pas indiquée je
saurai que je n'ai aucune chance avec
toi
ah ah
on
bruno
notre bruno bon et qu'est ce que tu as
écrit sur la lettre ben la vérité que je
suis amoureuse d'une autre personne
bon écoute faut que gerry barr et toi
qu'est ce qui t'arrive moi rien rien
t'as vu ta tête
toi il te plait bruno comme vous ça se
fait que par soit pas rendu compte
vous avez super en forme non je crois
pas non leicester allez on se prive sur
la largeur allégée du sprinter
super dur le devoir
on était passé pourquoi tu ne réponds
pas même message j'ai oublié mon
portable à la fête
ok très bien il faut que je dise quelque
chose à vrai dire moi aussi je crise
grave
raul nous a complètement tu te rends
compte qu'est ce qui t'a dit bah qui
venait de quitter berne et à des excuses
des conneries bah écoute oublie le
depuis quand c'est important pour toi
bats depuis que suis amoureuse j'ai pas
arrêté de pleurer tout le week-end je
fais quoi val chez pas aller c'est toi
l'experte pour ces trucs là mais surtout
essaye de te calme et on en reparle
après d'accord
deux ans sans se voir et tu continues à
être complètement paumé tu trembles en
plus elle est qu'est ce que tu fais ici
mes vieux vont pas m'inscrire au lycée
avant la prochaine rentrée
mais je suis revenu pour rester qui
s'était apparence ringarde valeria une
copine celle là les choses ont beaucoup
changé par ici ali on a vraiment passé
des bons moments mais aussi des moments
où on était très paumé et je ne veux
plus regretter quoi que ce soit tu me
croiras pas mais je suis amoureuse et il
t'a brisé le coeur c'est pour ça que
comme ça
là il est que je connaissais n'en
perdait pas un seul elle devrait revenir
je crois
exit pas avec écoute d'état plus mal
comme ça après tout fait comme moi tu
dis rien et puis c'est tout moi qui ai
rien ils finiront par s'en rendre compte
c'est tout je culpabilise
mais en fait rien de mal ne t'inquiète
pas ça notre copine
qu'est ce que tu veux qu'on lui dise
j'en sais rien d'un côté je crois qu'on
devrait lui dire avant que ça se
complique
mais d'un autre côté je sais pas comment
ils pourraient réagir n'exagère pas raul
est liée à leur forte malades jazzy de
suicider
qu'est ce que tu fais je lui fis la
rancoeur tu vas tout lui dire non mais
je veux éclaircir le fait qu'il se passe
rien entre elle et moi par conséquent
nous serons à même de connaître l'oeuvre
de john dans tous ses détails
il y est un ton portable bien
poursuivants james jones
et bien c'est bien c'est bien pour 4
bien des choses ont construit
récit
c'est moi
oui c'est vrai
car jouer
on s'est reconcentré
allez
les filles réception
[Applaudissements]
j'ai
rester qu'est ce qui se passe tu dois ou
quoi
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qu'ils aspirent
en manchette
p
l'orage toi esther sur le banc nantais
sur le banc à l'ailé
en bon allez allez allez
d'accord on a perdu mais seulement parce
que les adversaires ont eu de la chance
d'accord d'accord je le reconnais j'ai
été mauvaise je comprends vraiment pas
ce qui t'arrive je te jure que je peux
pas faire mieux
erreur au revoir esther d'accord
d'accord si je peux mais j'étais pas
bien aujourd'hui parce que tu as fait la
fête avec tes copains c'est ça non hier
soir j'ai fait mon devoir de fil c'est
ça ton problème esther tu veux tout à
voir il faut choisir
tu vas avoir de bonnes notes et faire
plaisir à tes parents général bosses tu
veux sortir avec tes potes et faire la
fête à leur sort mais oublie le volet je
suis désolé je veux jouer et bien à
partir de maintenant c'est ton univers
et je suis ton meilleur ami esther le
seul à savoir ce qui est le mieux pour
toi
non
à
athènes
m
ça
non on s'en va mais en at on pas espère
bons toiture est il t'as envie
je
bah qu'est ce qui t'arrive rien
rien ça va jamais dit rien
esther a une aventure avec son
entraîneur
tu es déjà tombée amoureuse de qui tu
devais pas
oui
bien plus d'une fois
et qu'est ce qu'on fait dans ces cas là
à vrai dire j'en ai aucune idée
c
ça
[Musique]
salut salut ça va bien et toi très bien
oui on va dans ma chambre
d'accord
on
[Musique]
c'est
super
n
[Musique]
je
je vais
[Musique]
allo valeria tu vas pas répondre non
plus quand je te parle c'est ça écoute
césar l'autre soir c'était sympa je me
suis bien amusé et tu le sais mais je
crois qu'il le restera ouais y'a un mac
dans le coin c'est ça j'ai un copain
bon je suis pas jaloux 1
pour info et si je meurs avant toi jeudi
un poste de l'envoyer pour moi non non
c'est à tes trop bonne des pathétiques
dis pas de conneries c'est dans la poche
maman je suis en train de bosser
actuellement je suis tout petit et
imparfaite mais je te promets que quand
je serai grande je ferai les plus jolies
fleurs du monde
pourquoi t'as pas répondu à mes messages
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec élise
connelly rien dit rien rien de chez rien
je lui ai dit que je préférais qu'on
reste copains et voilà
pourquoi on peut pas faire ça sans
devoir se cacher qu'est ce que tu fais
un pack
qu'est ce que c'est que ça le sac de
voyage que tu m'a offert mon nom ça j'ai
remarqué et où est ce que tu crois que
tu vas martin l'éducateur a organisé une
sortie camping mais tu m'avais promis
qu'il mènerait au bar je sais mais il ya
tellement de week-end pour t'aider
tellement peu d'occasions de faire du
camping avec eux tu ne peux pas de
surchauffe ce que tu veux tout le fait
non t'es génial arrose la plante juge
mois le camp
alors elie je peux pas je vais à la
campagne avec mon père pourquoi ta vie
tu pas les copains vous êtes gonflant
ouais bon on se voit quand je rentre
d'accord bisous
je te l'avais dit je me sens trop mal
ben c'est fini les portables seulement
toi et moi on se le mérite non bon faut
qu'on se dépêche on verra tetra pak y
est pas pour ça mais si j'ai regardé les
horaires on est en retard
on part en voiture commencée en voiture
t'as pas le permis non moi non mais lui
ici
[Musique]
la mini
à dimanche jesús à dimanche
[Applaudissements]
tout ça c'est pour nous tous mais
pourquoi tu m'as pas dit que tu étais
riche bas parce que je le suis pas en
fait c'est mes grands parents qu'ils le
sont ils ont des hôtels des centres de
loisirs zoo
je savais que tu aimais le cinéma et pas
autant je vais être réalisateur t'es
sérieux pour que tu en a jamais parlé
il prône aussi c'est l'humanité est ce
que je peux te poser une question chut
t'es mignon intelligent et en plus tu as
de la thune pourquoi l'éducateur c'est
ma mère qui m'a obligé
parce que je me sentais un vide dans
l'estomac quand est-ce que tu as
commencé à ressentir ça comme mon père
est mort
c'est l'homme qui avec toi sur ton
profil ça a été la dernière photo qu'on
a pris ensemble
il est mort jeanne
un soir il est sorti
et deux heures après le téléphone a
sonné on nous a dit qu'on avait retrouvé
sa voiture détruite et qu'on n'avait
rien pu faire pour le sauver
il avait des problèmes d'argent
il a failli ruiner l'entreprise de mon
grand-père et deux mois plus tard ben on
a reçu les indemnités de l'assurance
c'était pratiquement la même somme qu'il
avait perdu avec son investissement
et les réunions qu'on a tant aidé à
remplir ce vide non
c'est toi qui m'a aidé
chaque fois que que je te voyais cette
sensation disparaissait c'est pour ça
que j'ai quitté bien et c'est pour ça
que j'ai attendu sur le banc devant ta
porte
tu veux que j'arrête aucune idée on peut
patienter tout le temps que tu veux
tu fais ça
bonjour ma princesse
[Rires]
je vous vois des fous
[Musique]
[Rires]
là
[Musique]
m
toi
[Applaudissements]
d
mais
[Musique]
pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on peut travailler chez toi si tu veux
non je veux pas que ma mère nous chante
à crois qu'on était avec martin
dan
bon ben
c'est un super week-end
thür
un week-end vraiment parfait oui votre
père serait vraiment fier de son fils
vous voulez que je vous dise
votre père s'est déclaré à votre mère
dans cette maison le premier je t'aime
ne s'oublie jamais
ajouté
non non ferreux
non
je sais pas
je t'aime comment
je t'aime
pardon
[Musique]
je t'aime
alors le week end superbe
et les tourtereaux
comment ça les tourtereaux
ta mère m'a appelé pour confirmer qu'on
était avec martin et merde
elle m'a rien dit du tout mais elle est
inquiète pas j'ai compris la situation
je suis rentré dans son jeu et j'ai dit
quick on était tous là merci beaucoup de
rien hester il faudrait pour l'instant
que ça reste secret pour amy c'est ça
pas de problème
ce soir-là club non wen et je crois pas
que je pourrai bon fait à partir de
maintenant je pourrai plus venir autant
parce que la finale du championnat
approche et on va s'entraîner arrête
fais pas chier tu dois venir
hoyé j'essaierai mais moi je vous
garantis rien aucun bon les autres ce
soir sur la terrasse
bon à tout à l'heure ciao ok ça lui
on a fait 3000 $ mais espère et attend
un instant là je suis pressé qu'est ce
qu'il ya ben en fait
l'autre jour j'ai vu comment ton
entraîneur tu es traité non il n'y a pas
de quoi s'inquiéter rodrigo et sommes
pas bons mais dans ce cas là à vrai dire
je me suis inquiété d'accord et j'ai
posé des questions poser des questions à
qui et donc il n'est pas réglo bruno
arrête d'inventer des choses si ronan
c'est que il a déjà eu des problèmes
avec d'autres filles quoi dans la
dernière équipe où il était jeune fille
mais parce que tu fasses ça
bruno je sais que c'est toi la carte de
la saint valentin alors arrête
d'inventer des histoires sur rodrigo
parce que je sortirais pas avec toi ni
maintenant ni jamais
[Applaudissements]
j'ai
m
on plante fille esther tu viens georges
au plus tard je peux entrer oui qu'est
ce que tu fais ici on pourrait devoir
bien félicité ma joueuse préférée
j'ai bien joué la meilleure
non qu'est ce qui t'arrive
non art est pardon pardon
il ya des fois je m'étais trop jeune
pour moi non si tu es trop jeune
regarde toi c'est pas grave un tel
qu'une gamine sérieux vaut mieux en
rester là
non non on va pas rentrer quand j'ai
seulement besoin que que les choses se
fassent autrement
nous
s'il te plaît non non qu'est ce qui se
passe je te dis non esther leicester
revient tout de suite et c'est là comme
avant à bâle a laissé déjà les [ __ ]
arrête souffle pas comme ça allez il
faut que je vous dise quelque chose
ouais bah tout à l'heure alors c'est
peut-être pas le meilleur moment à
esther sa culture
moi j'en sais rien moi qu'est ce qui
t'arrive
oui non je te jure que je brûle d'envié
de savoir ce qui lui est arrivé à elle
elle le dira quand elle sera prête
je croyais qu'on était copain et qu'on
se raconte et absolument tout il ya des
fois il vaut mieux garder ses secrets
il faut juste trouver le meilleur moment
pour les rêver ah oui bah alors tu
voudrais pas savoir comment va mon
histoire avec raul écoute sur raul il ya
des choses que tu devrais savent qu'est
ce qui est à toi aussi tu crois que je
le perde ou quoi moi je crois pas du
tout je sais si je plais un mec à sa
façon d'embrasser et dans ma chambre
c'est confirmé il timbre et s'est
plusieurs fois même et ça sera pas la
dernière fois
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui t'arrive
des sorties avec elisabeth chez elle non
je déconne valait rien écoute moi je
suis dit non ça n'a été qu'un baiser
2 je te jure quoi tu me l'a pas dit pour
éviter ça moi j'ai confiance en toi
ouais super
[Musique]
m
je sais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce
non
parfois on doit choisir entre ce qui est
mauvais et ce qui est pire entre le
mensonge ou la vérité la plus cruelle
décidé implique le sacrifice de beaucoup
de choses décidée entre rester et
souffrir ou partir et vivre
je ne veux plus souffrir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec mon suisse chercher
[Musique]
oh
vous savez on dit que quand on est
enfant on croit qu'on est le centre de
l'univers et que c'est à l'adolescence
qu'on se rend compte qu'en réalité on
est tout seul
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
quelqu'un veut prendre la parole écoutez
l'année se termine c'est notre dernière
réunion
on a bien progressé ces derniers temps
non 1
il ya des fois plus tu connais des gens
plus tu te sens seul all
moi j'en resterai là
bon et bien on en reste là
même si vous n'êtes pas au meilleur de
votre forme je voulais vous dire qu'un
que pour moi ça a été un plaisir de vous
connaître et partager ces réunions avec
vous et bien un petit instant martin
je remercie beaucoup pour tous la toile
brute non que personne ne te fasse
douter de ce que tu veux
je m'en vais je m'en vais vivre à
barcelone avec mon père pourquoi parce
que j'ai l'impression qu'un changement
d'air me fera du bien c'est pour ça que
tu étais aussi triste et pourquoi tu ne
nous l'a pas dit tu pars quand j'ai mon
billet je parvins dit sitôt que ça bon
mais tu vas pas te met à pleurer un les
lames c'est pour la fête d'adieu mais
vous savez parfaitement que je déteste
les fêtes je déteste les as du match
âpre a pas cela on t'accompagnera à la
gare
m
penser que ta mère petite amie
aussi
t'a largué non
c'est toi qui l'a largué
voir c'est vraiment pas bon son
j
je peux passer très peur moi
vous faites
c'est un homme
[Musique]
le camerounais
je viens d'écouter
[Musique]
m
charest
[Applaudissements]
m
ces jeunes enfants
[Musique]
affaire
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais non tu dois t'en césar thibault
alet veto à césar thibault alet faut pas
le bouger il ya un accident dans le
tunnel de la caisse qu'elle soit 6,6 au
barça commence être le bordel la [ __ ]
si on s'échauffe et au look offre à
l'espace libre ouest avec l'ipo toi tu
pars pas non si les flics me choque pas
encore une fois il faudra en tôle et
c'est ton [ __ ] si tu pars ne m'appelle
fait jamais ta vie mouille-toi césar a
laissé sa [ __ ] mari
je
ah oui qu'est ce que tu fais ici je suis
venu payer l'amendé
esther pouvait pas sortir aussi tard je
voulais pas déranger je te rembourse dès
que je peux t'inquiète pas pour ça
ça va
raul
tu me ramènes chez moi
rien à redire comment ça dégage tu as
rien dit à la police
oh moi la paix mais dis moi si tu as des
nouvelles de pipeau t'avais qu'à rester
avec lui tu sais pas de quoi tu parles
s'arrêter j'aurais d'ailleurs à se dire
que les tiens je vais te casser la
gueule c'est ça [ __ ] j'y crois pas que
le camion sur toi de là il croise plus
jamais mon chemin
[Musique]
c'est qui ce connard une longue histoire
ouais ben j'ai toute la nuit devant moi
ça fait mal
plus mal que tous les coups arrêtent
pendant qu'on est ensemble suis jamais
sortie avec lui je répondais même pas à
ces messages mais ce soir j'avais besoin
de respirer j'ai merdé
il te plaît ce type non
t'en va pas tu crois qu'on pourrait
revenir en arrière comme si rien ne
s'était passé
non
je peux pas faire comme si cette soirée
n'avait jamais existé je peux pas
arrêter de penser que tu étais avec un
autre mec je veux pas faire marche
arrière
maintenant je sais ce que je veux
et c'est toi que je veux
demain on ira parler ali t'es sûr
j'en ai plein le dos de me cacher
[Musique]
massu
plus
[Musique]
ce
tu veux que j'arrête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au fait tu mérites ton très sûre qu'elle
voit bien sûr là sur la baby tu t'es sûr
parce que des fois il changer peut y
avoir une erreur oui oui alors c'est
vrai ça mérite une étude a choisi
mary autant que toi
la dernière réunion de notre club des
incompris
[Rires]
[Musique]
allez encore c'est bien
[Rires]
[Musique]
un bordelais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parra
vous vous savez que j'ai jamais trop
aimé parler
et je sais pas si je parlais pas parce
que j'avais pas de copains ou si j'avais
pas de copains parce que je parlais pas
mais de toute façon ça n'a plus
d'importance parce que maintenant c'est
vous mes copains
et même si maintenant je serai un petit
peu plus loin de vous
je vous jure que je ne vous oublierai
jamais je vous aime les a compris
pour m'accompagner
nous aussi si on va ranger corbin alors
mais rien c'est par là
tu vas chercher réseau j'ai toujours
voulu appeler un cheveu
alors tu as fini de faire la bouffonne
avec cette bande de nazes qu'est ce que
tu fais là on va faire la bringue oublie
l'est ces caisses qui allie c'est mes
copains des copains ils se foutent de
toi qu'est ce que tu racontes
tu vas me dire que tu étais pas rendu
compte de comment il se regarde tu es
aveugle quoi rouler valeria sortent
ensemble
à
mbaye
bond [ __ ]
ce thème
tél
comment vous avez pu
comment elie
si on t'a rien dit jusqu'à maintenant
c'est parce qu'on pensait que tu
finirais par le cheval [ __ ] du lycée
qui sortit des mecs en plus non élu je
t'en prie je pensais que c'était ma
copine
on peut en parler s'il te plaît
en fait
je crois qu'on n'a plus grand chose à se
dire
alesi avait raison elway c'est une vraie
copine
[Musique]
or mairie est pareil
le maire
médée
écoute
cours avant qu'il soit trop tard et
lance toi impossible de toute façon la
réponse aurait été n'est pas peu importe
si la réponse est non mairie demain tu
seras plus là ça n'enlèverait une épine
du pied de savoir ce qui aurait pu se
passer je peux pas
ouais
à
chacune
[Musique]
pour brûler partie par la a compté show
man tu tiens qu'est ce qu'il a non elle
ne répond pas
appelle sa mère elle devrait être au
courant
anosy et valeria la copine d'elisabeth
et bunge essaie de joindre il y met
décroche pas son téléphone
vous auriez un numéro de sa copine et
alicia est ce qu'elle vous a parlé
d'alicia dernièrement
oui elle vient de faire oui mais où ça
qu'est-ce que j'étais comme un automate
il comme tout le monde non pas comme
tout le monde tu m'as pas laissé tomber
toi je vais parler mes parents ils
peuvent pas m'obliger à finiront par
nous séparent et eli lilly sont déjà
arrivées héros comment son nom
amy a qu'une seule manière de rester
pour toujours
pourquoi pas d'amoureuse l'enfoiré la
meilleure copine est une [ __ ] étaient
parents me détestent ils nous détestent
tu le sais bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
raul sa mère avait raison elle est sur
le viaduc vient avec la bande
elie
je voudrais parler
tiens-toi des six fiches mal à pain
si tu sautes c'est le pèsera sur la
conscience le reste de sa vie
tes parents m'ont tout raconter sur
alicia mes parents des tests à lucia non
il y fit la déteste pas parce qu'elle
n'a jamais existé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non non non non j'ai pas tard et tu es
malade il ça peut s'arranger
personne ne te comprends que moi
personne prend soin de toi comme moi
non oui et on est amis et on sera des
amis pour toujours et lille et ils
écoutent pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
écoute moi s'il te plaît tu ne peux pas
te faire ça tu peux pas nous faire ça
s'il te plaît
[Musique]
oui et lui on est tous tes copains
mademoiselle la parfaite
les la mauviette hélas zorbit le
glandeur et la peau mais
tu sais peut-être qu'on est tous des
incompris mais entre nous on se comprend
bien tu es malade mais on va t'aider
[Musique]
tu vas vraiment les écouter
vient du froid
[Applaudissements]
l'adolescence est peut-être l'étape la
plus courte de notre vie mais c'est sans
doute la plus intense et la plus
palpitante de tout ce soir là on était
tous prêts à se dire adieu convaincu que
c'était la fin d'une étape incroyable de
notre avis on s'est bien planté ce soir
là c'était le début tout
mairie est parti à barcelone et elle a
eu la force de faire la chose qu'elle
souhaitait faire depuis très longtemps
être elle même mais c'est pas la seule
qui ce parti il ya des fois s'éloigner
l'unique manière de recommencer
le faudrait
par contre d'autres fois il suffit
seulement de regarder autour de soi pour
se rendre compte que ce qu'on cherchait
était là à portée de mal
[Musique]
finalement il suffisait d'ouvrir les
yeux et lui donner une chance
[Musique]
parce que pour réussir quelque chose il
faut prendre des risques si une chose
que j'ai appris durant cette époque
c'est que l'amour c'est comme la
première page d'un livre on sait comment
commence histoire mais pas comment elle
se termine parce qu'heureusement il
manque le meilleur
[Musique]
la vivre
ah là là là
[Musique]
marouane
copé 1
sam a super sel
d'ici là
proposée
de ce tour
rien
[Musique]
storey ramé
fillon
m
ce pas
parra passe à parcourir au port qu'elle
s'auto
aucun son
nous
[Musique]
il conclu
actu
bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas mal
[Musique]
mais
vous
[Musique]
m
on nettoie
sauna
une campagne
[Musique]
cette action
ça
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à ce jour
copé
demain je suis blessé
10 tennis